cheese doodle fingers forever what the  [ __ ] is a cheese doodle finger oh okay  i'm not a snack guy now i know what  you're talking about no i don't want  this at all i don't like that cheese  doodle finger it says the next one says  or pay 1.5 times things forever i feel  like i do that on accident as it is  because i just i would rather pay for  convenience like i'd rather look at a  sandwich on a sign and point to it  and have some guy make it for me as  opposed to make it myself i paid 40 for  a turkey wrap yesterday  yeah dude  like here over here and i'll do it again  too before i get cheese doodle fingers  [ __ ] off with that [ __ ] when it gets wet  it gets all shrivelly [ __ ] off with that